and researchers in britain have made a
very welcome discovery in the fight
against covid a low-cost
widely used anti-inflammatory has
improved the chances of survival for
seriously ill patients now this is the
first treatment so far
to show life-saving promise the medicine
dexamethasone
has reduced deaths by a full third among
patients on ventilators the drug though
does not bring any relief to patients
with milder
symptoms hospital staff are struggling
to help severely ill covered 19 patients
in the uk
though these images were recorded
several weeks ago scenes like these
are still being played out around the
world every day
brings more deaths but now
a glimmer of hope the worst hit country
in europe is hailing a major
breakthrough
scientists at oxford university say they
have identified the first drug that can
save the lives of covid19 patients
dexamethasone is a widely used steroid a
randomized trial showed it reduced death
rates by a third in patients on
ventilators
and by a fifth in patients receiving
oxygen
it really is showing quite a significant
effect and it's really important because
the drug itself
is very widely available it's on almost
every pharmacy shelf in every hospital
it's available throughout the world and
it's extremely cheap
so we've looked at the numbers and if we
treat eight patients in intensive care
with this drug
we'll save one life and the total cost
of treating all eight patients is only
about 40 pounds
40 pounds is about 50 us dollars the
drug works by reducing inflammation in
the lungs
the study results are still to be peer
reviewed but the uk
lost no time in approving it for use in
the country's health service
we've been stockpiling it since march so
we now have two hundred thousand courses
that are ready to go and we're
working with the nhs so that the nhs
standard treatment
for 19 will include dexamethasone
from this afternoon
as a generic drug dexamethasone is
readily available around the world
it's not a cure for covid19 but with no
vaccine yet available and infection
rates rising in many parts of the world
its potential is welcome news
so what exactly do we know about
dexamethasone and how the steroid
combats covert 19 well we put that
question to jason kindred chuck
he's a professor in virology at canada's
university of manitoba
so one of the things that we tend to
look at with these different types of
emerging viruses uh is the fact that
they tend to
basically increase the immune response
so essentially get an over stimulation
of
of the immune response which in most
cases actually is protective for us
but in many cases can actually increase
disease severity
so the hope with something like
dexamethasone is that rather than acting
directly on the virus and trying to
reduce the ability of the virus to
create more copies of itself
what the drugs are trying to do is
essentially reduce all that damage that
uh is part and parcel of an old
overactive immune system
we're trying to learn about this in real
time and we know that some of the
initial data that had come out
uh at the very start of this pandemic
had suggested that steroids
uh actually may exacerbate uh disease in
in those that are in the early stages
so i think one of the concerns right now
with with methazone
is that uh there you know would there be
the potential that if you treated
patients too early
that you might actually end up
increasing uh the the potential severity
of disease because it actually acts as
an anti-inflammatory so
i i think that we we have to look at
this as a potential game changer
for those patients that are actually in
severe disease distress
but we are still uh lacking for some
sort of a therapeutic
that will ultimately help reduce
infections in the very early stages of
disease